you can't even say slavery was bad now
in the Republican Party hey guys I'm off
the grid for August but msnbc's noted
racist lunatic Joy Reed is still at it
because you can't even say slavery was
bad now in the Republican party that's
how far it's gone and that's not even
Trump who had the policy it was
dissanted it is it is a profoundly uh
important note to make about that moment
with uh Congressman Donalds and DeSantis
and the party writ large that here you
have one of a handful of black
Republican members of the United States
Congress who are Republican
saying what he rightly should have said
this idea that you know black folks
actually benefited from slavery is just
crazy right but then the Santa is coming
you know clap backing on him the way he
did but notice none of those members
that were pushing him out to be this
next person none of them came out and
said you know what a don't mess with my
boy
B he's right no right no one no one and
so that that again tells you about the
trumpian narrative you go into this
space thinking you're locked arms and
you're all kind of moving the same way
you're not baby boo you're not yeah so
you're not useful you're by yourself
you're useful until you're not and that
being not useful can happen as quickly
as congressman